Kevin very very thin this is as thin as
I've ever seen you look really good I
think as I've been in a long long time
honestly this is the weight that I think
I was at when I tricked my wife into
marriage to Maryann years ago and she's
been very good she didn't she never over
the course of all those years like as I
ballooned and stuff she was never like
you got a stop or you got a change or
anything like that and she doesn't
really like make a big deal about it now
like she's like oh you look good but
she's not like oh thank Christ right I
was so tired of [ __ ] up fat like how
she still Fox a fat man she's just not
as bad
so let me your health is good now health
is wonderful I had a heart attack for
those that don't follow this sort of
thing about two months and change ago
and I had a hundred percent blockage in
the el-ad artery which is the big fat
one that goes across the heart they call
it the Widowmaker because in 80% of the
cases of a hundred percent blockage
people die what did what caused it
genetic or your food well I asked the
doctor that because I was like your
drugs but goddamn it don't touch my weak
so I asked the doctors both my doctors
my new cardiologist dr. Layton I'm and
my GP doctor Israel and I was just like
I asked them both about weed they
cleared me on weed so I was okay on that
but I asked dr. Layton I'm I said like
three years ago I lost 80 pounds 85
pounds because I cut sugar out of my
life so I've dropped a bunch of weight
I'm not nearly as fat as I ever was I
said I walk a dog up a hill every day it
granted his little miniature dachshund
so it's like fat guy and a little dog
it's comedic to look at but it's also
healthy as well as I can understand why
I would have this hard tech man and he's
like I'm you know I was good that you
changed your life and stuff but like
that probably kept it from happening a
few years ago he's gone hundred percent
blockage he's gone number one your
genetics play a part in it what are your
parents like and he was their hearts and
I said my mom's got two stents in her
heart she's got heart condition here
goes well there you go what about your
dad I was like my dad died of a massive
heart attack and so he's like
genetically you know maybe that's
something to keep an eye on he said but
the
out of blockage you had that's that
started in childhood that didn't come
recently he's going that's a lifetime
heating so I was sitting there going all
those [ __ ] Twinkies and childhood and
then I remembered like we didn't have
enough money for [ __ ] Twinkies so I
was like all those little debbie swiss
delights of childhood class my veins
that i was paying for years later so he
went in there with a stent opened it up
and like they keep you lucid throughout
your in Twilight I guess like they don't
knock you out because I was
chit-chatting old time at one point I
was singing the Degrassi theme song and
[ __ ] to them well I'm [ __ ] with your
heart yeah while he's and how they get
to your hardest through your groin right
femoral artery so he's down below he's
in my crotch and I was singing to Gracia
interesting and whatever it takes I feel
like that's your truest you hopeful song
did it and and as if you know that
Degrassi the next generation show it's
always some black course of children of
course it it which also sounds hopeful
so I was thinking that to myself
men are H probably shouldn't have that
in the back of our heads but I would be
in the same boat as you I think we
should make it less creepy it's not
about you teen girls it's about hitman I
don't want to die right middle-age men
it's a song for teen girls joining the
song real quick
hi yes while we're chatting sure yeah
see this is oh yeah we were on a table
and they're like you have an 80% chance
of dying this is what's running through
my head whatever it's yeah something
cheery huh you know you're a good person
you don't I mean that that oh I mean it
was either this or stairway to heaven so
you take this is especially you tape
that night you were going to tape to
well like last night I got that little
like a little shooting thing in my chest
which sometimes you just get like a
little discomfort my heart was it like
did you have any type of a thing before
or not sure before yes now in retrospect
last year I did Call of Duty's got a
game within a game and this one was
called Raven the Redwoods it's a zombie
killing game so they asked me if I
wanted to be at they always get like a Z
list celebrity to be in and she I think
Hasselhoff was what before me and they
were like do you want to do it and I
said sure can I bring J and they put J
in it as well so I was a playable
character in the video game at one point
like you I was the boss stage I became
like the big boss and yet
Killman think so the company that makes
the game they were like can you come
play it on Twitch
for an hour one day and I was like oh my
god that'd be fun so I don't normally do
the first-person shooter games I'm a
scroll man from back in the day pitfall
is my speed so this I kind of let him
take control the guy who was in charge
and we went through that game like
wicked fast cuz he's a pretty great
gamer so about 55 minutes into the hour
we were almost done I started feeling
like really nauseated like and I don't
get nauseated I felt like I was gonna
throw up so as I came in where's the
nearest bathroom he's like we're almost
done and I was like I know I'll come
right back but I gotta get out to the
bathroom so I he's across the hall got
out to the hallway was real staggered
got into the bathroom first thing I did
it was like a public men's room [ __ ]
first thing I do so [ __ ] up I was so
overcome I laid down on the floor and I
remember seeing feet in the stall and I
remember thinking like this poor guy is
just like yeah oh no here he comes with
the Sun but I didn't care because I felt
so bad and in that moment while I was
lying there I said oh my god am I having
a heart attack is this what a heart
attack feels it hurt or just nausea it
was nausea and it was this weird
sensation not pain of like ow but like a
complete undoing of who I was like I had
no thing or no diagnosis beyond this
ain't right but in that moment when I
was on the bathroom floor I was like
Christ is this a heart attack and I
threw up a little just like I did the
night like years later when I did the
show or a year later when I did the show
it's show time show I threw up and then
suddenly I felt hundred percent better
and so I got up but I left the bathroom
and put folks are outside they're like
you okay I was like I just I felt [ __ ]
up but I threw up but I now I feel
better they're like oh you don't play
games much do you I said no they're like
you had motion sickness and I was like
really and they're like yeah motion
sickness is like when you're kind of
going through the game if you don't play
it very often that happens to a lot of
people okay so you know I was like oh
[ __ ] gave you a reason for it that made
sense I was like 46 so it can't be a
heart attack
like you know Wow and but that was the
only time I ever thought heart so when
this
was going on February 25th I was
shooting the special and you've shot
many specials you know it's like you
shoot two and they combine them into one
picture so I shot the first show
supposed to be an hour and I went two
hours so afterwards they like will just
cut from there [ __ ] the second show and
I was like I got to separate hours for
the second show let's just do it all
we'll have a record
so between shows I went I was in the
green room and Jordan Monsanto is Jason
muses wife she runs our company she was
there she was overseeing and then she
was like I'm not gonna stay around for
the second show she's like I've heard
you talk and the only other person there
was Emily who does my hair which is
stupid because I wear a hat all great so
she was there too and I felt ill Eliza
can you guys like leave like I just
don't like I feel like I might throw up
I smile lay down on the floor or
something like that same [ __ ] things
are a bit from the way on the floor the
men's room so I so unless I should point
out the dulcet tones of Brian Johnson
himself so I was laid down on the floor
and and I you know threw up again vile
not like chunky [ __ ] just bile
so I I felt a minor better and then
stood up I was sweating profusely but I
sweat when I breathed so I didn't take
that as a sign and so Emily poked her
head and she goes here all right and I
was like yeah so can you do me a favor
and plug in the hair dryer and just like
[ __ ] dry me like just I'm all I'm all
sweaty so she was doing that and she's
like your [ __ ] neck it's freezing I
was like is it not normally and she goes
no you're very normally warm so I was
like I gotta lay down before the next
show man and they found me a couch I
tried to lay down I couldn't get
comfortable and then I couldn't catch my
breath
like I could breathe but it was shallow
couldn't hit the top and come back down
yeah so then I was like maybe I should
sit up and I sat up in a chair and I put
my arms up to like try to help breathe
I'm you know I'm no doctor but I'm just
well yeah and then Jordan comes over and
you know they were trying to leave me
alone she peeks around the corner and
she's like you're right I was like I
feel really bad I was like I've never
felt like this before I don't know if I
should maybe do the second show and
she's like we cancelled it and I was
like why the [ __ ] would you cancel the
second show and she's like you I've
never seen you be sick this is scary
so maybe we you should see a doctor I
was like all right and I
we're working we go and she's like it's
Sunday there are no doctors so we called
it ambulance and I was like don't why
would the [ __ ] would you do that this is
embarrassing I just I guarantee you I've
smoked too much weed right this
ambulance gonna show up man like this oh
[ __ ] and she's like they're already here
and firemen come first when he called
the paramedics so they came in 6 brawny
ass firemen four of which were young and
looked at me like is that Silent Bob
celebrating a touchdown because my hands
were up in the air and so also the
medics come in two paramedics look the
same like Bobbsey Twins man and woman
and [ __ ] the guy's like hey I'm gonna
take your blood pressure how you doing I
said kick catch my breath and then the
ladies got this box got wires in it and
stuff like this puts it down she opens
it up and she goes I would put these
leads on you cuz okay and I'm sitting in
the chair and this is like 32 pounds ago
but even now I would [ __ ] hate this
she Yanks my [ __ ] joke oh like a
sound person yeah humiliated you know
like flock wears layers and spends his
life covering his shitty Milius and it
was like they were like his brawny ass
fireman all sitting there like Jason's
wife and stuff and you're sitting and
not even standing she's like I get these
on you I was like I said my [ __ ]
friends wife's red there she never seen
much I said I'd never seen much this I
wear shirt in the [ __ ] shower she
goes well I gotta go to Monte I'll hold
my shirt out and you reach under and
then put him on and use my nipples as
guideposts and she looks at the guy
she's like we ain't got time for this
and the guys like yeah we really gotta
get to work and I held the shirt out she
put the [ __ ] and then she looks at him
and he goes you know what we're gonna
take you to the hospital I said why and
he goes cuz we're so close he's going
it's so close
we're take you there just to be sure
he's gone we're seeing things here and I
got an idea but like maybe somebody
better than I should see you and I was
embarrassed
he kept if he tried manic you that's
call keeping stress down way as they
were taking out he goes you're being
real calm man that's great that's what's
gonna get you through this and there's a
dude behind him--as goes that's what's
gonna save his life and I still didn't
put it together cuz I was like I guess
that's just meta talk yeah
nobody said like you're having a heart
attack right so they told me the like
we're gonna get you in this chair over
here do you ever go to the hospital he
says is that well I visited relatives
but I never been in myself he goes all
you're gonna have fun he's going ever
been in an ambulance no we'd like him
out of that thing of like being a little
kid at the dentist's office lollipop
yeah told me made it a treat I'm like
this is gonna be fun yeah you know star
the show generally and you know I was
like I'm alright let's do this he's
right real fast cuz we have a chair here
we gotta get you to the chair they
wouldnt let you walk to the in owns it
wouldn't let me walk to the [ __ ]
chair so I want to get up and they go
whoa stay right there and I go I gotta
get to the chair they're like we'll get
you there and that's when he goes boys
and the six brawny firemen come over and
pick my fat ass like like it was nothing
like I was light as a feather stiff as a
board picked me right the [ __ ] up put me
down in the other chair man boom I was
like that was the most fun I've had and
I was like if I live through this I'm
gonna hire big men to pick me it was fun
nobody's pick me up in years I've been a
large human being for a while at this
point are you alarmed are you like art
this is serious I'm more embarrassed and
I honestly think that I'm gonna get to
the hospital and they're gonna be like
you have a lot of mucus built up clearly
you've smoked too much weed today don't
do that anymore and they didn't like
they told the crowd for the second show
that I'd thrown out well they didn't
tell my throwing up they said it's food
poisoning because they heard that I okay
nobody knew it was going on so as I was
getting wheeled out everyone from the
sex shows wave and instead like good
feel better kept and there was one guy
doing the finger down his throat
Universal I'm throwing up sitting in the
sign language for throwing up so I
didn't know what he meant and I thought
I was like like picking a fight I was
like you telling me to suck your dick
like I'm ambulance bring me the hospital
and get into the ER and in the ER that's
where I meet dr. Leighton I'm the
cardiologist the guy will become a
cardiologist goes hey how are you I'm
dr. Leighton
hi how are you and I'm already hooked me
up to Shiv and he goes we're gonna get
you upstairs as quickly as possible he
goes because you know is urgent you're
having a massive heart attack he told
you right there in the yard and I was
like what that was the first time those
that term had been introduced and I was
like what no impossible guys yeah big
one he's going so we're gonna take you
upstairs got to go up inside he right
away if it's what I think it is we gotta
go to work fast so I'll see you upstairs
and I was like all right and I still not
like Wat and tipping tables I was like
okay well and I still honestly like you
know how you're like you know they don't
know anything like yeah I was sitting
there going like this doctor this
cardiologist [ __ ] so they had you
hooked up you an IV and and they started
[ __ ] on me and what I didn't know is
they were starting me on [ __ ] drugs
like I had no idea because during the
operation I was lucid and tell you still
sitting there going like I'm gonna be so
embarrassed when they bring me up to
surgery and realize it's just too much
we just smoke pot yes I was so like oh
man this is gonna be so bad and and and
I'm gonna be made fun of by my wife cuz
I made fun of her once like she smoked
up two hits off of one of my joints and
we had to call an ambulance because she
was like I'm gonna die and I was like
nobody's ever died from weed and she's
like you're trying not [ __ ] kill she
thought I was in on some scam we got
people there
the medics showed up and [ __ ] and they
were like the lady comes issues what's
the matter I heard there was an overdose
I was like it's my wife she smokes some
of my weed she goes oh my god this goes
upstairs she's Jennifer's all freaked
out on the couch and [ __ ] and she goes
Jennifer is that your name Jennifer she
goes uh-huh she goes Jennifer first off
nobody has ever died from smoking weed
you're gonna be fine we're gonna get you
through this she's going you know you
should probably do eat a lot of fun food
have sex with your husband this is gonna
wear off in three hours she's are you
sure I've got a daughter to take so you
know I knew my wife would make fun of me
for this but I got they after Laden Heim
leaves
guy comes in with a bucket and the
shaver and he goes I got to shave your
groin I said why and he goes that's how
to get up to your heart through your
groin through the femoral
it's okay like above or below blow the
sob are just the balls that go inside
that's what I said I was just like well
wait as Devin's
oh well what's the groin to you man and
it goes because it could be different
like growing out you've to me as a dick
and it goes it's here on the side and I
said alright man he goes to take your
jorts off is it where the ball meet the
leg right there it is
right it's the crook it's like the Ken
part of you if you had shown just where
the legs meet the [ __ ] torso so I
took off my dress but I left my
underwear on you good and then he goes
you got to take your underwear off and I
said I'm not can't do that and he goes
we got to shave you I said bro they just
told me I had a heart attack and if you
make me take my underwear off run all
these people I will have a second heart
attack and that one's gonna be on you
and stuff because what am I supposed to
do I said I will pull the underwear off
to the side and you get in there shave a
landing strip or Brazilian me and then
I'll do it on the other side and he goes
we ain't got time for this and I was
like I can't I don't know another way to
do it it's funny your body shame is
literally making your heart attack
treatment like I'm sitting and that's
how shameful I am in my body I was like
I'd rather die than like [ __ ] have 13
people in the ER probably won't remember
me see my dick but all I'm thinking
about is the one cat in there who's like
Silent Bob it's not Bob's little dick
and he takes a picture and then I got to
deal with that for the rest of my life
and you know lost you in eighty million
dollars please it'll be all over
figure you have a small dick anyway who
cares get around the [ __ ] so they bring
me upstairs and they pull me into the
o.r and dr. Leighton times there he goes
why is his underwear on he goes like he
don't want to take him off he says he's
got body shame issues a nice take over
from there I'm like yeah doc man I'm
like I might dig as real small guys we
got time for this and he grabs my
underwear and Yanks off my body just
whoosh you realize that's keeping so
long oh my god it was thrilled as much
as I was happy to get lifted by six guys
into a chair I was like this is the
right relation you got me to to as you
were going through massive heart attack
but then you hear out in the hallway
understand which want the car to small
ticket
undress me he goes for my Jersey as well
and and I was at the Jersey is still
like a later zor-el that is least I
could pull it down to cover my dick but
he wants to go to work there and [ __ ] he
goes Guinness Jersey off and I said I
have the presence of mind to lie I was
like no this is my lucky Jersey if we're
going to an operation I need to wear
this it's so lucky why do you have a
[ __ ] exactly just yanked it off man
then I was just naked as the day I was
born and the last time I was that fully
naked was in the hospital when I was
[ __ ] born so it'd been 47 years are
you not naked that often never I'm never
never nude I don't have a pair of jean
shorts typed like days do to her but I'm
always clad in something really oh god
yeah even although after I've lately I
lost 32 pounds and my wife she's like
you are you take your shirt off very
easily now cuz normally I would like go
in my closet like that even around the
person you're with right yeah my guess
she's mentioned it last night where
she's here with me in New York we're
gonna see Springsteen tonight at the
Broadway show so last night like we were
hanging out talking like after I did
press on the balcony smokin and then we
both like we were like let's let's put
let's go watch homeland we put on like I
started putting on my PJs she goes this
is a good idea and she went into another
room put her on her PJs and then we got
into bed and she was like so [ __ ] up
we've been like [ __ ] each other for
20 years we still go to separate rooms
to get undressed like we know what each
other looks like I was like I know but
like I'm just always worried you're
gonna catch me at that one horrible
angle we're sure like his tits are
bigger than mine and then she's out the
[ __ ] door or something like that so I
had a lot of body shame man he got me
over at the [ __ ] quick fast hurry and
he he threw that [ __ ] thing up me I
was on drugs I didn't know like my wife
told me afterwards man like I got out of
the o.r and she goes are you okay and I
was like I had a massive heart attack
man but this guy doctors behind me I
think he saved my life and as I get it's
crazy I had a great time and she wanted
to write and I said no they didn't give
me nothing man I'm sober the whole time
and the doctor behind me goes he was on
fentanyl right now
so I heard that I was like I'm gonna so
the he told me one-up me and he goes
yeah it's what I thought hundred percent
blockage he's going to you're fully
blocked in your l ad it's going we got
to do Mirchi angioplasty emergency
angioplasty and put a stent in there I
said okay and he goes he goes your comic
book guy he goes you know what they call
that artery the one that's blocked up I
said no he goes that's called the
Widowmaker and I said why he goes in and
80% of cases where there's a hundred
percent blockage the patient dies but
you're gonna be in the 20% so I'm really
good at what I do and I said all right
doc do me a favor if you can saved my
life and he goes I'll try and then he
disappeared into my crotch and went to
[ __ ] work and [ __ ] and I just laid
there thinking about like alright this
is this is that moment you dreaded not
like I'm having a heart attack like this
could be the end 80/20 are the worst
odds I've ever had going for me my life
I'm aware of unless you know there was a
time where there's an axe murderer right
behind me you got a cell phone call and
got distracted oh that I'll never know
so suddenly you know I was trying to
cognitively reframe and be like you know
[ __ ] 5050 is chance is dying every
time you walk out of your house yeah I
get hit by a car struck by lightning
trip over [ __ ] dog to them but you're
Juggalo and you're dying bleeding out
being but I love dogs and should so like
anyway you could go but 80/20 was
[ __ ] higher odds so I said how long
is this thing taking this whole process
to me it's like I don't know 15 minutes
who knows but like as I was drugged
about you are in the twilight stage but
I asked him later on like when I went to
see the cardiologist there's like how
long it take you to get from up my groin
to my heart he's just like oh no less
than a minute I was like you [ __ ]
serious and he was like yeah he's like
that's what I do is like you know we
know how to do it we're trained I guess
the guy in the bathroom it only took him
15 seconds
so I sat there and instead of a bit
[ __ ] my whole life and always
assumed when faced with death I'd be
like [ __ ] whose dick - I gotta suck
to stop this from happening but I didn't
go that way I didn't [ __ ] like I
didn't start bargaining with God because
I figured God we'd be like you made
dogma go [ __ ] yourself buddy Christ so I
just sat there and instead thought about
like my life and and as if this is it
what you're you know where are you
what's your view no if I can take your
pulse had an art weird how do you feel
and I felt pretty good like I felt
really good I felt at peace I was
totally like kind of like wow if this is
the end like not bad like you had a good
job you had a good life like you had
great family you got married you had a
family of your own
like I felt more grateful than anything
else right sitting there going like no
this ain't [ __ ] fair and Baba's like
if you [ __ ] died aged 47
maybe that's why should happen to you so
early maybe that's why clerks have it at
age 22 23 like so that you could enjoy
this and then you were always meant to
check out [ __ ] early and if that's
the case if you're gonna [ __ ] die
here on the table like don't [ __ ] like
if you have to pay the ferryman tonight
just [ __ ] chuck him the tube it's get
on the boat and go you had a great
[ __ ] time so you are you have pretty
calm - you were like kind of resigned to
whatever happens don't like yes I was
like hopefully hopefully I'm in that
twenty this guy seems confident but if
I'm not if I'm in the 80 like they at
one point after he told me that there's
somebody in the or held up a phone and
said your wife is on the phone you want
to talk to her and I went to go speak to
her of course to be like oh my god
you'll never believe where I'm at
because she didn't know she wasn't there
anything but then I realized if I take
the phone and I start talking to her
that's that's an admission of like this
could be the last time you talked to
your wife that's why they give you a
phone in the or is it yeah so I was like
um you know what I said tell her I'll
call her back after the operation and so
you know the guy said something - no and
then again then I said what was her
reaction he goes she sounds bad yeah but
at that point I was kind of like I
thought talking or would decrease my
chances I thought that would be like
well here it is
our final talk yeah I was Shifa Hospital
like 20 minutes ago ma'am I was in
Glendale and so she came like between
while I was when I came out of Oh our
she was there and then she was beating
herself up for not going to the show but
she never goes to my show she [ __ ]
lives with me and hears this [ __ ] all
day yeah so she never really goes to
show you know if she went to the show
maybe they wouldn't have called the
ambulance they may have deferred to her
exactly and she may have said I just lay
there yes yeah knowing her she would
have been like yeah lay there he's fine
critically so he went to work and and he
did it man if I could hold me out of it
and should save my life so it was crazy
and the next day the nutritionist came
in and my kid was there my kids never
lost anybody close to her she's lost
grandparents and stuff but they're
usually on the other side of the country
like my dad died and she knew him but
she was baby and there was long time ago
so this was a big deal like it was the
closest she's come to like some sort of
[ __ ] tragedy and her very privileged
life so she wouldn't leave the hospital
she just [ __ ] stayed there and stared
at me the whole time and when the
nutritionist came in the nutrition is
like you had 100% blockage there's a lot
of as bad it's a lot of cholesterol I
said yeah I know she's gone you might
want to think about going plant-based
for a diet and my kid is a vegan and she
immediately shot up it was like yes yes
listen to this woman be a vegan and my
kid's been trying to like she's flipped
everyone in the house like my wife and
my in-laws but Jen's parents Byron and
Gail they've all went vegan and I was
the last you know meat-eater animal food
product person in the house and she was
never shitty about a shame campaign like
she's young she's 18 to come in 19 but
she never like tried to beat me until I
switch ended up and [ __ ] like that she'd
be subtle every once in a while I'd be
drinking milk it should be like not your
mom not your milk she's like is that
grandma's titty milk I was like I
[ __ ] hope she goes to be your
mother's milk you drink you know
supposed to drink cow's milk he stole
milk from some baby cow house when you
go to school so she was never really
that hardcore about it but when she saw
the window she was like make him be a
vegan and now the the nutrition was like
I'm I got make him be anything but like
it's proven that like people have high
cholesterol if you go plant-based and
stuff
it just clears up it starts breaking
down and going away so I figured I was a
guy man I'll try it being vegan for like
at least a year 47 years I [ __ ] ate
whatever the [ __ ] wanted let me try a
year their way and see how it goes and
stuff so I used to be very happy in this
life now I'm very vegan and now you are
then yeah yeah so far man it's been two
months since the heart attack and so far
no animal food products that I know of
like I mean is it awful or is it
honestly it's worth mentioning you don't
like vegetables or fruit jeez yeah so
what do you want never went veggie or
vegetarian or vegan cuz I'm like well I
don't like any of that [ __ ] I found
things that are not animal food products
that I can eat that still aren't like
from the earth which is like yeah it
sucked here's a turnip with dirt on it
so what do you eat so I'm a real big
pinto beans fan I'm a beans guy and I
realized that like beans are like way
high in protein and stuff and they let
you go on beans they don't bust your
balls over bean so I guess healthy
healthy enough they want you to eat of
course like [ __ ] you know asparagus
and kale and [ __ ] like that and baby
steps right now for me I was like let me
drop the weight first like my GP was
like after the hearts actions like Kevin
you should just lose 50 pounds instantly
it'll make all of this easier so I was
like okay so I'm down I've weighed in in
a week and a half because I've been on
the road but I was lastwe and I was down
32 pounds Wow
so that was the first thing I said I was
all changed my eating and I can't commit
to like now I'm gonna eat the greens and
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] slowly you know
I'll find a way into them and stuff but
I had to figure out [ __ ] I could eat
that wasn't animal food product related
so winds up being a lot of [ __ ] pinto
beans chickpeas became the thing that
saved my life I never had a chickpea
before and suddenly I did I was like
this [ __ ] I've paid for that we like to
say women
hate to be dismissive so yeah so but you
love chickpeas loving the death but is
it Harvey - you can't eat the deserts
because you say you're not eating sugar
so a lot of those [ __ ] desserts are
like the almond ice cream is really good
but you can't eat it that's the thing
like I've been going to I've been in New
York like I was here last week do [ __ ]
then I went to Iowa to do shows then I
came back this week to do stuff and
stuff so while I've been here I've been
going over to Brooklyn to hit champs
diner which is a vegan joint vegan
comfort food so you get like a meatball
sub that looks and tastes like a [ __ ]
meatball sub because you know it's bread
and marinara big ingredients there and
then they throw a meatball in and the
meatball is covered by the bread and
marinara so you don't necessarily know
it's close enough where you're not like
you know oh god this is pepper or some
so [ __ ] it literally tastes like kind of
meatball and then I had a Philly
cheesesteak there my kid was like trying
to Philly cheesesteak I was like you
can't fake that and they did it's good
yeah like champs in Manhattan and I know
they it's in Brooklyn chance diner so
they're on their menu they've got a lot
of desserts and the desserts are like
you know you're like I'm vegan and I'm
already eating vegan food so if this
desserts vegan no animal is harmed it's
all good and then you remember oh [ __ ]
you don't eat sugar either so suddenly
you can't dive into that end of the pool
that's the one saving grace it seems of
veganism is they don't [ __ ] with sugar
though like sugar comes from the earth
that's natural but for me I don't [ __ ]
with sugar anymore period so I don't get
the benefit Joanne Weight Watchers and
they made me an ambassador like Oprah
and DJ Khaled and stuff so it's
wonderful and they have this program you
know it's based on points right where
it's like you got this many points don't
go above this or you'll gain weight keep
it below this you lose weight but they
added this thing to it called freestyle
where they put foods that have no point
value so you can eat some of this if you
lived off this list you would never
touch your [ __ ] points and you'd be
dropping weight like crazy I guess it
came in demand from a bunch of Weight
Watchers customers were like hey man
give us some freebie food and they
looked at at scientific they just like
the act of eating so you have freely
feel you can some free food that doesn't
hit your thirty like I got 32 points to
play with and after that I can't eat
anything more for them yes celery
[ __ ] carrots all vegetables and
fruits are free they're not blended or
zero but the what killed me was chicken
and turkey were on the list
I was a goddamn it cuz I love chicken
and turkey and [ __ ] and I gave that's
zero zero there's nothing as long it
can't be like you know [ __ ] barbecue
chicken cuz then that's barbecue sauce
and [ __ ] like that but just clean lean
to a turkey or chicken like without
anything on it zero on the list now if
you put salt on it that's like 1 or 2
points put gravy on it that's like 4 or
5 points the more you dress it up that's
where the points come yeah but like
being the in the last two months what I
realized is I used to love turkey but
then I realized I didn't I don't love
turkey I love gravy like if you gave me
a flat piece of Turkey be like eat it
I'd be like well not plane like that's
you dry but I like putting [ __ ] on it
same with chicken I used to think I was
a real chicken fan but I just love
barbecue sauce well you'll have tofurkey
this year that's right then there's also
that like and back I tried at one point
to like beef not me at one point not
just tofurkey good come out of a sneaker
[Laughter]
but they've gone very good with this
vegan food lately where that you get
away with eating lost [ __ ] comfort food
now it's not healthy for you because
it's made with oils gas and [ __ ] but at
least you could get a taste of the old
things used you just eating falafels
like crazy I'm doing a lot of hummus man
I've become like middle-eastern ate a
[ __ ] ton of hummus try it the Comedy
Cellar upstairs the olive tree they have
great hummus and they've really good
middle-eastern food is good upstairs
yeah I found you have to find places no
matter where I go now I always like
enter into Google like that city and
vegan comfort food and so Los Angeles is
the absolute best
Brooklyn's champs is fantastic I was
just in Iowa nothing there now no but I
was where was I where I was like are you
[ __ ] kidding me
they had a vegan joint goddamnit where
was it one places I wouldn't uh Oregon I
guess that makes sense
I was in Oregon and Washington that -
really good being in comfort food joints
and stuff so it's out there if you're
into that sort of thing I I'm not a lot
of people have been reached out to buy
and promo organizations and vegan
organizations go on hey you're one of us
and come speak but I'm not like I don't
do it because I'm like I believe in love
animals I do love animals but like I've
you know I also
the [ __ ] nice chicken with with [ __ ]
you it's your health you donor it's more
for the health than anything out so I
don't want to come off as like you know
do you begin by default
really doesn't matter do you still get
that like I eat a lot of bad food and
like I'm used to after a meal it's
supposed to feel heavy and dense and I
know that I ate and that's what eating
feels like mm-hmm but I've heard that
like when you start eating healthy you
don't get that yeah even obviously I've
I haven't even I couldn't even say for
sure that I'm eating healthy but I know
I'm eating far less and I kind of
retrained myself to eat like now eat
like one meal a day if that Wow some
days like I try to like I wake up and I
try to get as deep into the day as
possible without hitting a meal cuz I
used to get like oh I'm hungry it's
morning and you know there's so much
[ __ ] propaganda bout breakfast you got
to eat a [ __ ] breakfast so I used to
work like that like I wake up [ __ ]
feed and then that'll start the day but
the body ray cronies who's a as a diet
program or a lifestyle program could
call just sides which is all vegetable
based and stuff like he pointed out like
the body is not people you say you know
the body's a car and food is the fuel
and that's not really the case the body
is an oil refinery and the food is raw
crude that you shove in to the body and
then the body has to process that it's a
usable energy and if you have too much
if it's too like sitting around it just
stores it like you would store [ __ ]
crude oil that you'll get to later on so
my body was just this [ __ ] crude oil
factory if stored material that like one
day I'll need this energy so when I
started kind of leaning into fasting the
body just started eating all the energy
that it had stored for all this time and
so I've learned to respond to like the
hunger it's like it's not hunger it's a
momentary pang that kind of [ __ ] past
right and then I'm not really hungry
until 2 or 3 o'clock so I try to make it
as deeply into the day as I can and
that's how the way it's been kind of
coming off yeah you look really thin
then you look great I saw you in the
hallway before I came in and like number
one you lost it years ago I was always
so impressed by that but that you kept
it off that's the thing but it's nice
what people like you look great but in
the back of my mind there's a fact
it's like it's only for a while yes I'm
gonna get to that [ __ ] booth egg and
then we're gonna look at the way we use
yeah it's very it's hard but I guess if
your health is at stake you got if I can
do it that's the one thing this time
around that feels different than any
other time I've ever tried to lose
weight I'm like now you're playing it's
a gunpoint yeah yeah but before it was
more about in vanity or ego like I look
like fat piece of [ __ ]
well now I'm like I don't want to die
and you were in the 20% you're gonna
waste it now yes I mean the 20 there was
this beautiful woman dude who I did good
day New York and when I before I went in
she was I can't take a picture she was
taking pictures and stuff and she got it
wrong a few times so we kept taking
pictures kept taking pictures and the
good day New York people like we gotta
go we were running late so after the
segment was done it came out and the
lady was there and she's like I watched
your segment she's gone and I found out
your background she's going you she's
going it's amazing that you lift she's
going you're gonna live a long time and
I was like how do you know that and
she's like I know things like that I'm
spooky like that she's going but like
what you went through your beer a long
time I don't know I bet you I bought
myself like maybe another year but you
know you're absolutely wrong here you go
on you're gonna do great things like it
was so random and wonderful in New York
or somebody some stranger who and she's
not like I meet a lot of strangers who
are like fungus on the Bob or like I
love the podcast
this is my [ __ ] don't know who the
[ __ ] I am other than like I took a
picture and she gives you that like read
like it's better than her being well I
would have loved if she was like thinner
because I was I would it came out but to
have a stranger just be like hey man
like you're gonna do well this is always
a nice thing he's one of the things you
love about me but not but not to kill
the niceness or that but you know
fairness 15 minutes later she was
playing around the corner
[ __ ] against the building soul has
to [ __ ] sooner or later the stand-up
special premieres next Friday May 11th
at 9 p.m. on Showtime silent but deadly
hmm so great name by the way yeah it was
the name of the show before the heart
attack so you know I was just playing
silent Bob and then also you know fajr
party heart attack and then after the
heart attack I was like oh we got to
keep it at what point did it occur to
you that like this would have been my
final work
so where'd you say that it still hasn't
really landed they told me when I left
the hospital they're like you may run
into a bout of depression
I said why they like heart attack
victims it happens to a lot of them like
sooner or later the mortality event
catches up to them and it hits them in
an emotional or psychological way and I
was very interested in that cuz like you
know the whole thing to me is like this
is a ride let's see where it goes and
I've never been depressed so I'm like
what would that be like like I know what
others depressions like but I was kind
of curious what mine like what would be
my blues like where would I go and [ __ ]
so it never really never really kicked
in you know I didn't have the depression
bout kick in so I was kind of like
bummed by that but what was the original
question I this was your final work like
so they say the reason you have the
depression is because you're like oh my
god I almost died and I had definitely
have had moments where I was like well I
was [ __ ] close like imagine if it
didn't go the way it did like you've
you're I'm out there now I turn it into
a pithy [ __ ] anecdote and a bit like
it becomes [ __ ] fodder for the
material schirmer's for the show and you
go on with life and stuff and but every
once in a while I think about I was like
wow that's [ __ ] close but immediately
the other side the rationalization side
cognitively reframes it goes you're
close to dying every moment of your life
like don't treat this anymore spry like
for some reason my one side of my brain
won't let the other side of the brain
revel in it it all could be if I don't
work that's what I always feel like so
but I did as I cut this special because
you know it was two hours and we had to
cut it down to an hour so I went through
it and I wasn't gonna lose this story
lose this story and as I'm watching and
I was like if this was the final
document like not bad like I'm not
saying the shows that great but I was
like you'd be okay with that I was okay
especially considering like at least
there'd be something at least my last
work wasn't yoga hosers you know the
only thing I thought when I was on the
table I was like I really don't want to
die because the last movie I made was
yoga hosers and I want to make Jane
style about reboots so at least I go out
on that note but so so for me like it
was I don't know as I watched it like I
was like if I died I would have been out
okay with this that being your final
piece yeah like this Honey sure it's
about family
like I talked about my family a lot and
and the work like it's a real nice
encapsulation of who I am slash was so
if I died we have one minute left
speaking of movies real quick well we
have a minute I was just thinking like
last night I saw that movie tusk when it
came out I can't I haven't stopped
thinking about it so like it just lays
with you I think yes because of the man
to my left Brian Johnson years ago like
in the middle of it you know I made
clerks the mall rats are chasing a man
was after chasing Amy that you guys shot
vulgar or after after chasing Annie so
after chasing amy like I gave bribes
always pushing bride into doing making a
movie or particularly back then making a
movie because that was the thing I did
and it worked and I was like I wouldn't
have made my movie without bribry is the
Randall character without without bride
there would be no Randall and clerks so
I said you got if I can make a movie and
one day he decided to make a movie and
it was this movie vulgar it's called
vulgar it's about a clown who gets raped
by three guys he's crazy crazy
exploitation movie and I remember when I
saw the flick I was a goddamn it like he
made the movie not the exact movie but
he made the kind of movie that I wanted
to make like I wanted to be that
filmmaker I believe me I'm happy to be
the one I became and stuff and clerks
worked out but but like I love
underground I love like [ __ ] edge I
loved like the idea of he made this
modern day exploitation movie [ __ ] cult
film like like the highest compliment we
could pay a film back in the day was
that's [ __ ] up that movies [ __ ] up
yeah and he made a fucked-up movie I
want to make a [ __ ] up movie so I
eventually made tusk that's great a
Brian Kenner yeah well the show is
anything that Kevin Smith on Twitter
Brian thank you for coming and eating it
so talk too much but I'm happy that you
came in and I see you fine Kevin I'm
happy that you're here and no thank you
so much the lines you have are good